change
on the back
um next up we have Hannah Lee she got
her PhD at Stanford and operations
research she's currently doing a postdoc
at MIT before she starts at Columbia
business school
um next year
uh she's an expert in inference external
design for online marketplaces
um particular in the presence of
interference between making different
experiments and treatments
um
thanks for the intro all right so the
work that I'm going to be talking about
today is kind of a collection of
different results from three pieces of
work that it worked on during my PhD and
I'll try to focus on some of the newer
ongoing work and this is work with my
PhD advisors from West Johari and
Gabriel Weintraub
so let's talk about platforms and
decision making so if you're a platform
say something like Airbnb you have
countless choices in how to design your
platform how many listings are each
customer going to see how everything's
going to be highlighted what kind of
pricing fee structures are each side of
the market going to engage in things
like that and how do platforms tackle
these problems well a lot of what they
do they rely on experimentation
uh it's also called A B test or
depending on different fields randomized
controlled trials
um so to what to go through an example
let's say that Airbnb a lodging platform
is considering a new intervention where
they want to show higher quality listing
photos to the customers before they
decide to introduce this to everyone
they want to know how it affects metrics
that they care about in a metrics that
they care about could be do the number
of bookings increase on the market
the goal here is to estimate what we
call this Global treatment effect so
this is the difference uh in the metrics
that you care about between a world
where everyone sees this intervention
everyone sees the nicer pictures and a
world where no one sees it
and what they'll do is they'll run an
experiment they'll give the intervention
to some customers not to others so
treatment customers will see the better
photos and the control customers won't
and then use the outcomes of the
treatment control customers to estimate
the global treatment effect
typically you'll just take the average
of both the two groups need to subtract
them
um and so there's a lot of advantages to
making decisions this way when you do
this you now have evidence for what
decisions you you should uh what what
kind of interventions you should enact
um so this allows for data-driven uh
basically data-driven decision making
it didn't have this experimentation you
might have to rely purely on intuition
for deciding whether or not you should
introduce something or relying on what
some people call hippo relying on the
highest paid person's opinion in the
room
um but this really allows us to actually
use data in this decision decision
making process
um so that's all well and good
but the issue is that in a lot of
marketplace settings you'll actually
have bias estimates of your treatment
effect the estimates that you're getting
from the experiment will be
systematically biased from the true
Global treatment effect
and let me walk through briefly why this
happened and what you're going to see is
that in these Marketplace platforms you
have competition you have economic
competition that will then create
interference and then bias estimates
so
again the S demand that you care about
is This Global treatment effect and
suppose that you introduce this customer
side experiment so that uh a control
customer will see this old uh the old
photos and a treatment customer will
actually see the new listing photos but
they might overlap in the listings that
they see or interact with
and now suppose that this treatment
makes the treatment customer more likely
to book than a control customer
suppose that this treatment customer
then books one of these listings that
listing then becomes unavailable for the
control customer and so what you did
here is by changing what the treatment
customer sees you're actually increasing
the amount of competition for the
control customer and reducing the supply
available to them
and so in this experiment condition
they're actually facing more competition
they would have been in the global
control world and so these experimental
outcomes for the control customer are
actually not representative of a global
control outcome
because of this you'll end up
underestimating the amount of bookings
by control customers overestimating the
bookings like treatment customers and
you'll end up overestimating the
treatment effect in this case
um and so more generally whenever you
change one customer's booking
probability you change the supply
available for other customers and
whenever you change how attractive one
listing looks you change how other
listings look in comparison
and so when you have constrained Supply
constrained demand this will create
interference in your Marketplace
all right so where does the prior work
stand uh in this topic a lot of the
prior work here so far is focused on
this these biased treatment effect
estimates
um and so specifically there's been a
couple uh recent works that have shown
that the size of the bias can be quite
large
um people have found instances where the
size of the bias is somewhere between 30
of the treatment effect two in some
cases 230
um and so it is indeed a big problem and
this is something that's come to the
attention of not only academics but also
industry practitioners and a lot of
these papers are done in collaboration
with practitioners
foreign
and so these platforms have started to
realize that yes interference is an
issue this bias is an issue and so
they've started to adopt some uh methods
to help reduce this treatment effect
bias the most common ones are cluster
randomization and Switchback testing in
some of our work in our earlier work
we've introduced this two-sided
randomization as well and generally
there's a couple other topics as well
that leverage the structure of this
Marketplace better to help reduce the
bias
um and so we also have some work
um so this is from two uh previous
papers uh
thinking about when the bias is large
versus small so if you look at some of
these empirical papers that find you
know the size of biases between two is
between 30 to 230 you might wonder which
case are you in when is it bad when it
said not
um and so in some of our work we tackle
this and we show that the size of the
bias is heavily dependent on the amount
of supply and demand and ballots in your
Marketplace as well as the type of
experiment that you're running
um so I'm happy to talk about this later
um
but what I'm going to focus on this top
in this talk actually is
taking a step back from here and saying
yes we know the treatment effect by uh
bias is there but how does this
ultimately affect the decisions that a
platform makes from these experiments
and hopefully by the end of this talk
you'll see that there's more to this
problem of how experiments affect
decisions than just the treatment effect
bias
and what I'll try to explain is that
these interference effects in these
marketplaces can actually create
multiple types of biases and in the
presence of multiple biases sometimes
fixing just one bias can actually hurt
the decisions that you're making
and so we'll uh go take this a little
higher level view of experiment design
and decision making
so let me first go through how a
platform uses experiments to make
decisions in the first place
so a platform will run an experiment
um and then they'll usually decide up
front some sort of significance level
that they care about Alpha equals 0.05
and some sort of launch threshold C I
can think of this threshold as some sort
of cost of launching this new
intervention where you say if the
benefit of launching these higher
quality photos the entire Market is
better than the cost than we want to
launch otherwise we don't foreign
experiment and from the outcomes you
come up you come to a point estimate
under Global treatment effect
and then you estimate the standard error
of this uh estimator This Global
treatment effect estimator I'm trying to
understand the distribution that it's
coming from
from the standard errors that you then
create your confidence interval so in
this case would be a 95 confidence
interval if alpha alpha equals 0.05
and
a simple decision heuristic that we'll
use here is a heuristic where we say if
the confidence interval lies Above This
bound C or above this cost C then we're
going to launch
and so this is kind of one example of
kind of a standard decision-making
protocol that a platform would use there
are certainly more complicated ones as
well sometimes platforms we'll look at
several different metrics and
um but this is kind of the core of this
decision making
and so to bring this back to where the
current literature stands
well interference can actually create
multiple errors along this
decision-making pipeline
prior work has mostly focused on this
first one here this uh biased estimates
of the treatment effect but we're what
we're going to do in this work is also
talk about biases in the standard error
estimates and then how these biases
propagate to the confidence intervals
and decisions that are made from it
so here what we're going to do is we're
going to Define this Dynamic Marketplace
model of a two-sided Marketplace and
then use this model to study first what
kind of biases arise in the standard
error estimates
and then how do these biases in the
standard error estimates and treatment
effect estimates then affect our
decisions
and similar to amnesia's talk actually
this uh work is a little bit on the
boundary between or and more causal
inference methods where this the types
of questions here experiments with
interference violations of Supa this is
very much a causal inference problem but
the way we're going to address this is
more through an or modeling method where
we Model A Marketplace come up with this
basically a data generating process for
them for the market and then study how
estimators perform in this model
and so takeaways um from this talk the
results that we find are that in a large
class of interventions um called
positive interventions which I'll Define
later uh does treatment effect bias and
standard error bias cause the platform
to launch too often
um and uh there are interactions between
these two biases and sometimes fixing
one bias can actually hurt your
decisions but we do provide a method to
help reduce the standard error bias that
also improves your decisions later on
later on the pipeline
all right so that's the goal and now
I'll just jump straight into the model
what we're going to Define is a
continuous time Markov chain model of a
two-sided Market where first you have
customers customers can have different
types um types can represent for example
an Airbnb what location you want to buy
from or how price sensitive you are
and different customers will arrive at
different rates according to the poisson
arrival process
when they come there's going to be some
set of available listings on the
platform
and customers will interact with these
listings
so first the customer will form some
sort of consideration set
um so you can think of this as what does
the customer even see on the platform as
a result of search and recommendation
systems
um and here each of these listings is
considered uh is included in the
considerations that with some
probability Alpha uh
yes Alpha that can depend on both the
customer and listing type so in listings
can also have different types this can
represent things like number of bedrooms
they have location things like that
now from this consideration process the
customer then makes a choice about
whether or not to book a listing and if
so which one and this section is modeled
using a multinomial logic model where
the customer can have different
utilities for listing the different type
as well as some outside option
now say one of these listings is booked
that listing then becomes unavailable
for some amount of time before it later
replenishes in the rate at which it
replenishes is governed by this Tau of
theta parameter which is also a function
of the listing type
and So within this model this is kind of
a model of how the marketplace uh
Dynamics will move this is actually a
Markov chain model where the state of
your system is a number of available
listings at any given time and so these
arrival rates and replenishment rates
will govern how the state transitions of
your system
and again this is a data generating
process for the underlying Market but we
don't assume that the platform actually
knows any of this
what the platform does though is they
run experiments on these users or on
these listings
um and there's two common types of
experiments we'll mostly focus on a
customer side experiment in this talk
and so here this is the same type of
experiment that is in the earlier
motivating example where customers are
randomized into treatment and control
if they're in the treatment group they
see the shinier photos if they're in the
control group they see the old photos
what that amounts to in the context of
the model is this changes the utility
that they have for a given listing
um and then
um kind of a naive uh Corvette Thompson
or a Herbert Thompson estimator is this
uh estimator given here where you just
take the number of treatment bookings
normalized by the size of the treatment
group minus the number of control
bookings normal again normalized
and since in our model we consider the
rate of the bookings
um so we normalize by time as well
you can also randomize on the other side
of the market we have some work on this
about differences in the bias between
these two types of experiments but I
largely won't go into that in this talk
the quantities are okay so then once we
have this markup chain model we're going
to study how the system behaves in these
three counterfactual worlds in this
world where everyone has this like new
set of utilities Global treatment uh or
Global control or the experiment world
and our s demand what we want to
estimate is This Global treatment in
fact there we go is This Global
treatment effect right here so this is
the steady state difference in the rate
of bookings between the treatment group
and the control group
and again the estimator is just this
time average of from your observed
bookings
something else that we'll want to know
about our estimator is the standard
error and the standard error is just
defined to be the standard deviation of
the the GTE hat sampling distribution
all right
and so this is how we're going to
analyze these experiments and now we're
going to go through each of these steps
in this decision making Pipeline and and
kind of figure out what happens in each
one what goes wrong and how can we fix
that
so first we have this point estimate in
your treatment effect
um and so again a lot of Prior work is
focused on this specific step
um so things about like looking at the
size of this bias work that we have
looking on like how the size of the bias
depends on um supply and demand and
balance that all falls into this one
but
the takeaway uh for this step for now is
first we're going to focus on a certain
class of interventions
this class of interventions is something
that we're going to call positive
interventions
these are interventions that will
increase all customers utilities for the
listings of the platform
this doesn't have to be a uniform
increase people can still have
heterogeneous treatment effects but what
I'm saying is I'm ruling out the case
for this treatment makes some people
like to listen more it makes other
people like the listening class
examples of such interventions could be
things like these higher quality photos
or maybe discount codes which everyone
would like
um potentially two different amounts but
in this setting what we prove is that in
a positive intervention these naive
estimates uh customer side or listing
side experiments they will overestimate
the magnitude of the treatment effect
um
and yeah so this I'll have you keep this
in mind but I'll largely move to this
next step um and we'll we'll come back
to this in a couple minutes
all right so now what's been less
studied so far is what are the estimates
in the standard error
and it turns out that so again uh
finding the standard error it turns out
that in these you know Marketplace
settings if you do the naive standard
error estimates you'll again get biased
estimates
and what happens here is that how
platforms typically do is that they'll
assume that all individuals are
independent which again like I said
because there's interference this isn't
true and so this will treat biased
estimates
and here this is a plot from our
simulation showing what would happen in
a Marketplace what does the bias look
like as a function of on the x-axis the
time Horizon of the experiment
um and here this is uh these are
calibrated simulations to uh some like
real
uh two-sided marketplaces and one thing
that we find is that uh here when the
time Horizon is shorter for an
experiment you actually have much worse
bias and the size of your standard error
bias is roughly around 30 the size of
the actual standard error but as this uh
experiment experiment runs for a longer
time the relative size of your standard
error or the um and of the bias will
actually decrease
and so what's happening here
why why does it look like this um oh
and also like note in particular that
here we're often we're always
underestimating the true standard error
so that's saying when I uh I'm always
like thinking I'm more confident in my
estimate than I truly am
so what's happening here well
basically what we're looking at is we're
looking at the variance of this
expression this number of treatment
bookings minus number of controlled
bookings which is the sum of the
variants of the treatment bookings plus
the sum of the control bookings minus
the covariance between these two groups
and in naive the typical standard error
estimates that platforms run they'll
just completely ignore this they'll say
that everyone's independent and ignore
that last term
however
this there is a strong covariance uh
there is a strong correlation between
the number of treatment bookings and the
number of controlled bookings
so again here we can see that as
uh this is the behavior of the
covariance and it follows a very similar
pattern as the standard error bias where
there's a much higher covariance at
Scales covariance when you have a
shorter experiment and much less
covariance correlation when you have a
longer time Horizon
and so what's happening here is that
again there's tree there's a competition
between the treatment control customers
when treatment customers book more
listings they're less available for the
control and so you have this negative
correlation there that will then lead
you to underestimate your variance
it's a sense of the time scale okay so
10 is compared to how
to help inventory
so how many units of experimentation
yeah yeah so that's a good question
um just depends on
this has been a lot of parameters
um so I think in the calibrated setting
that we found uh I think it corresponds
to something more like in this range
here where you have a 10 bias but this
definitely depends on how long the
experiments are actually running what's
your minimum technical effect that
you're aiming for
um so it depends on a lot of things like
that
foreign
standard errors and
trying to have for both standard errors
is that would not address this type of
issue is this tissue of a different
nature
yeah so there
there is
there are different types of customers
or different types of listings and there
are heterogeneous
um
experience our characters and
differences as well a lot of that would
be addressed by the clustering but in
addition to that you have this
interference effects
um where when one customer goes to
Taiwan this affects the customer type 2
which affects the customer time three
and a lot of that is not as isn't
addressed as far as I know
it's a good try to think of those
customers as pertaining to the same time
book and clustered with that assignment
if they're like looking around the same
time
so actually there is something that is
pretty similar to
um some methods that we take uh
yeah so maybe I'll talk about how they
do stuff that yeah I'll talk about how
we address this and I think there are
there is a lot of like intuition that
means of the same idea
yeah so to sum up um in this talk just
like what we saw in the treatment effect
bias
um in the treatment of black estimates
we see the same effects happening in
standard error estimates whereas the
fact that there's competition in this
Marketplace is creating interference and
then Finance
all right so given this how do you
reduce the standard error bias
one thing is uh when we look at this
earlier plot we see that the size of the
bias seems to be decreasing the time
Horizon so a very simple uh proposal is
just to run a longer experiment here
um and indeed we show that for a
customer side experiment as we increase
the time Horizon the size of the bias
approaches zero
for the standard error and what's
Happening Here is very similar to the
intuition presented earlier it's the uh
this idea that as a customer you're
probably affected by the customer who
came just before you and maybe the ones
just before them but you're probably not
affected by a customer who came you know
a week ago or a month ago or a year ago
and so there's probably some limit on
the amount of customers who are actually
affecting you
and so as you're increasing the length
of the time Horizon of the experiment uh
for any individual customer your
going to be less uh let's see less
influenced by a larger proportion of the
customers
what this means in a mathematical
language uh so what we end up showing is
that this system is a regenerative
regenerative process so this Markov
chain is a regenerative regenerative
process and you can actually think that
this Markov chain is consisting of
independent chunks in time and these
chunks are defined by when the Markov
chain hits a certain state of the system
again
so for example
um say there are 100 available 100
listings in the market
um and it replenishes whenever you hit a
hundred uh if I'm coming to uh the mark
you're sorry if I'm a customer and I'm
coming to the market I see 100 available
listings it doesn't I'm not affected by
whoever came just before that
and so there's these limits uh you as a
customer only affected by people who
came in the same chunk or block as you
and you're independent of everyone else
and so when you're on this longer time
Horizon you get less bias in your
standard error
we also have a second method for
reducing the standard error bias because
in this first method well you don't
always want to have to run longer
experiments there are opportunity costs
to doing so
um sometimes it's just not feasible So
within a fixed time Horizon how can you
reduce standard error bias
well here the method that we propose
using is what's called a Time series
block bootstrap method and so I won't
spend too much time on this but for
standard bootstrap methods what you'll
do is you'll resample individuals from
your population and then from these
resampled individuals you'll calculate
things that you're interested in you'll
calculate quantities that you're
interested in repeat this multiple times
and get some sort of uh estimate of how
much you can differ here
we're going to do here though is we're
going to use a bootstrap technique
that's modified for time series data in
particular that really captures this
local interference the fact that you as
a customer are also influenced by the
customers who came in a nearby time
and so what we do here is uh we have
resampled blocks from this time series
um and we create like a pseudo time
series so from this observed time series
what we're going to do is sample a block
of some fixed length cape and then we're
going to append that to our pseudo time
series and then sample another block
append that to our time series and then
keep doing this until we get a new
pseudo time series of the same length as
the original
and so from each of these bootstrap runs
this gives you some new pseudo time
series from which you can calculate this
treatment effect estimator
now you repeat this capital B times
and then you'll have capital B number of
these like treatment estimators and you
calculate the standard deviation of them
and this gives you the bootstrap this
time series bootstrap estimate of your
standard error
all right so how does this perform
um we show that in a number of different
settings for a customer side experiment
we the bootstrap boot trap standard
error estimation has actually less bias
than the naive standard error estimate
both for customer side experiments which
and also for listing side experiments
which we largely didn't get into today
but it has benefits for both
there's a caveat though uh so yes this
time series boot trapping method can
help mitigate this bias but there is a
caveat where you do need to tune the
block lengths that you're sampling
um so again what I've kind of said is
that yes in this regenerative process
you're bounded by uh you're kind of
bounded in the time
basically the number of customers who
affect you they have to be in the same
immediate chunk but these block lanes
have to be long enough to capture the
Dynamics in each of these blocks in each
of these chunks and you as a platform
might not know that up front and so
there is some tuning that you have to do
here to get better performance
um so this is like this is still ongoing
work
all right so now I've talked about a
spice estimates in your standard error
and in your treatment effect bias and
then both of these will come together to
affect the coverage of your confidence
intervals
um
I
won't really spend too much time on this
but basically when you have this
treatment effect bias it's shifting your
competence intervals right or left and
when you have these standard error
biases it's either decreasing or
increasing the width of your confidence
intervals more or less than they should
be
and so this will create errors in your
standard um in your coverage and we
actually do characterize the asymptotic
coverage of the confidence intervals as
a function of the treatment effect bias
standard error bias and true standard
error
well largely uh um yeah so let's skip
over that and largely just talk about
how this influences the decisions that
you as a platform are going to make
and so recall that our goal in these
settings is to launch this new
intervention whenever the treatment
effect is larger than the cost
and the decision heuristic that we're
using is we're going to launch if this
competence interval lies above that cost
threshold
and we're going to evaluate our
decisions uh our decision is correct if
we launched if and only if the true
treatment effect is larger than the cost
and so here you can kind of have two
errors that you can make with these
decisions a false positive launch
decision where you are launching the
plot you are launching the intervention
but you shouldn't be where uh you the
true treatment effect is less than the
cost or sorry is less than the cost but
you think it's more than the cost
um you can also have a false negative
error where you are saying that this
treatment which is actually good you
don't think it's good I'm not going to
launch it
all right and so now let's go back to
this class of interventions that we've
talked about earlier the set of positive
interventions
these are interventions that um
basically help everyone and so here what
we see is that
again we're overestimating the size of
the treatment effect in our experiments
and so this is going to be shifting your
confidence intervals
um to the right
and we're underestimating the true
standard error here
if you put this together what does this
mean in terms of decisions well we're
going to uh systematically bias our
estimates upward and so we're going to
think that our treatment effects are
better than they are and we're going to
be more competent in our decisions than
we really should be and so this is
leading us to overestimate or sorry this
is going to lead us to actually over
launch
more often there are a lot of settings
where you shouldn't be launching this
new intervention but you are
so then how do the methods that we
propose earlier of reducing the standard
error bias how do they impact these
decisions
it turns out that fixing these biases
doesn't necessarily equate to improving
the decisions that you're making
and so we'll start with
let's see
we'll start with this first method of
reducing reducing a standard error where
you just run a longer experiment
if you run a longer experiment
um uh you can see as you increase the
time Horizon then your standard error
bias uh is decreasing which is good
that's what we wanted
however if you look um so again consider
a scenario where the treatment effect is
actually less than the cost
here anytime you decide to launch that's
a false positive
and in this scenario if you look at the
proportion of false positive launches
this is actually increasing in the time
Horizon
which is bad so now it's like the longer
experiments that we run the worst
decisions we're making
which you certainly don't want What's
Happening Here is that as you're running
these uh longer time uh Horizon
experiments the actual standard error of
your estimates will be decreasing
together with the standard error bias
and so now we'll be increasingly
confident on the size of well we'll be
increasingly competent on our bias
treatment effects estimates and we'll be
launching more often
um so this is also kind of an
illustration of how this idea of
interference is not something that can
be fixed by having more data and in this
case when you have more data more
observations you're actually making a
worse experience worse decisions
well I promised earlier that we do have
some method that would help improve
decisions
um and so
we turn to the second method that we
proposed this reducing the standard
error bias using this block bootstrap
technique
and here considering the same scenario
we find that this bootstrap method
actually reduces the standard error bias
and also reduces the false positive
launches
um and so here
foreign
I'm showing on the y-axis the number of
false positive launches so the higher
the bar the worse decisions you're
making
this blue bar here is what happens when
you just use your naive standard error
estimate and then in this red bar here
we're showing what happens when you
replace that standard error estimate
with your bootstrap standard error and
so here we're having much fewer false
positive launches so we're doing much
better in terms of decision making
and this third bar here the screen bar
is what happens when you run a longer
experiment so this is the other method
of reducing err estimates this here
actually increases the number of bad
decisions that you're making
um and so we've tested this in several
different parameter regimes both in
regimes where you have a lot more uh
apply the demand in settings where you
have roughly equal amounts of supply and
demand and in settings where you have a
lot more demand than Supply
and we see similar patterns across these
uh across these regimes where this
bootstrap method does improve the false
positive launches does decrease the
false positive launches however this
naive or sorry just running a longer
experiment does not
and so this is kind of all just to say
that if what you care about is making
better decisions you do have to be
thoughtful about
the errors the the fact that there are
multiple types of errors in your
platform in your experiment and how you
uh how you address these errors it's
possible to fix some errors get worse
decisions but it's also possible to fix
the errors and get better decisions so
there are a lot of interactions there
now to just sum up
what we show is that both the treatment
effect estimates and standard error
estimates will interact with each other
create incorrect decisions
we proposed two methods of reducing the
standard error bias
one of which is running uh these longer
experiments which persons with decisions
the others using this block Booth trap
technique this time series Booth track
technique which actually improves the
decisions and the cases that we study
and so
and so um yeah there's basically a lot
more to look at than just the treatment
effect biases that a lot of the current
literature is focus on there's a lot
more happening around these experiments
um so as open questions one thing you
might ask is what happens when we
combine these standard error bias
reduction methods with the treatment uh
treatment effect bias reduction methods
that are already in the literature
things like cluster randomization
Switchback testing or things that you
know uh leverage different structures in
the marketplace what happens uh with the
decisions once we do that
and in general also just more study on
the resulting decisions that we're
making from these experiments and also
how these platforms are using these
experiments to begin with
so
oftentimes platforms have very
structured methods of implementing these
experiments sometimes they'll do a ramp
up experiments where you start you
introduce this intervention to one
percent of your customers then you if it
looks okay you better put up to 10 it
looks promising you keep ramping it up
well in that context how does
interference affect the decisions that
you're making there how do these
different types of biases affect these
decisions platforms are also running all
kinds of simultaneous experiments and
making decisions from there about what
experiments you run next so basically
taking a little more of a high level
view about how platforms use these
experiments and how this usage is
affected by interference or different
statistical methods underlining them
so with that I will wrap up and uh take
time for questions
yes um yeah so this is a really good
question
um because
yes basically I got I gloss over that
kind of stuff that I'm just around
there's a lot more to be done here and
basically evaluating how good our
decisions are because sure I could
reduce my false positives by never
launching ever and then but then that
would of course reduce your false
negatives
um so we see that in these scenarios we
actually don't increase the false
negatives although I I will say right
now we're definitely looking for a
better metric just in terms of how to
evaluate the decisions that we're
outputting
but we still increase the time Horizon
eventually it will make the decision
worse right
yes because it reduced the bias
yeah because then your standard error
would still be getting smaller and
smaller
um and then you'd still be more
confident about your biases yeah all
right
give me a sense of why do we need to
stick attention
there are some types that are negatively
effective to help
that change things oh yes
um
sure yes so I asked them about
there are some types of customers
to get out yeah so if there are like if
there's an intervention where some
customers uh been like in lower other
customers like it less you'll still have
the same interest different structures
um and like this the competition will
still be there
um what you don't have guarantees on
then is whether you're overestimating a
treatment time or under
so there it could be possible that there
are edge cases where you actually end up
underestimating the treatment effect
even when the treatment effect is uh
positive things like that
um and so like a lot of our results
actually in the paper do extend to it
our various papers to send to more
general settings like that
um things where I said like uh so the
size of the bias depends on your supply
and demanding balance those all hold
um but this overestimations that's not
and really here I focus on this uh
setting where you overestimate because
it's a little bit more clean to look at
how the decisions are
uh when you can potentially overestimate
or underestimate and your standard error
estimates are too narrow
it's not clear what kind of errors that
will be excited
um if you are trying to figure out
whether whether an intervention is
positive or negative could the bias and
GTE be helpful
yes
um
yes okay so I think uh what what this
question is also saying is like suppose
there's uh no cost to launching we just
want to know if it's positive or
negative
um and so here yeah if the treatment
effect is negative then uh you'll just
have a net uh you'll overestimate
magnitude and treatment effect or even
more negative
um and so yeah that's actually helping
you if your soul uh your the goal is
just to determine positive
and that's actually equivalent to even
the decision-making piece where you have
no cost to launch a product and you only
care about if it's possible yeah
and yeah so here uh
you really are sensitive to do you care
about the costs or do you strictly care
about just this time
three years since
you go to school
the choice is actually going to be just
important it's a great assumption that
somebody far behind is
sorry if this will do better if there's
a difference so uh
foreign
oh that's an interesting question
yeah so here like the
implicit assumption that I've been
making is that a customer's behavior is
only a function of the current available
listings and what you're saying is what
if it's a function of the current
available listings and also some
parameter of the ratings of that of that
person
um
to be honest I haven't thought about
that that certainly makes it more
complicated
um
it you you couldn't imagine scenarios
where
people pause it I won't um sterilize
right now
um but it's certainly more complicated
and I'm happy to talk offline
right